CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER: This
year's Princeton-Fung Global
Forum addresses one of the most
important political and social
issues of our time --
can liberty survive
the digital age?
CECILIA ROUSE: We're so
happy to be here in Berlin,
because we just believe it's
so important that Princeton get
out into the world -- and we
mean that at all levels --
that our students
have an opportunity
to live and learn
and work abroad,
that our faculty
also have a chance
to interact with faculty
at other institutions,
and that other faculty and
policymakers and students
from around the world have a
chance to interact as well.
ASA CRAIG: We did a
short walking tour
in the pouring down
rain the other day.
It was interesting to see
sort of a community that's
been in development, to
see how people bounce back
and move forward, and then
at the same time, about some
of the impacts of different
aspects of history.
ELISABETH DONAHUE: Putting on
a conference in Berlin, Germany,
with the organization and
planning going on in Princeton,
New Jersey, has a
lot of challenges.
We asked the panelists
to get together
to really work out
the themes that they
want to cover in their panels.
It's not meant to
be a session where
they plan every single thing
that they're going to say,
but helps them figure
out what major themes
and what major topics they want
to make sure to hit when they
get on stage at the forum.
VINTON CERF: We're here
to talk about the internet
and what has happened over the
course of the last 40 years
since it was invented and
roughly 35 years since it
was turned on in 1983.
I think that it would be
impossible to overemphasize
how critical public trust
is in this internet online
environment.
And it is eroding,
with good reason,
because there are frailties
in the system that need
to be remedied technically.
There are problems
that can only be
addressed by common agreements
across national boundaries.
There are technologies, like
in the internet of things,
that need to be
implemented in a way that
regains people's trust in
the safety and reliability
of those devices.
CECILIA ROUSE: It is a pleasure
to introduce our first panel
the "world" wide web.
JULIE BRILL: I do
agree that there
are technological
issues that absolutely
should be addressed, full stop.
But I don't think
the alternative
is to have the government
control these platforms.
One of the things I'm
very passionate about
is to make sure that we
set up systems and controls
and ethical frameworks,
co-regulatory frameworks,
as well as laws, that will
work when the people in power
are people you agree
with, as well as when
the people in power are people
with whom you vehemently
disagree.
You need to
future-proof whatever
you're going to set up
so that it will work,
whatever your political
persuasion is.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
FRED KAPLAN: Thank
you for coming here.
[APPLAUSE]
In terms of our
overall question,
can liberty survive
the digital age,
what is it precisely that
concerns you the most?
David.
DAVID DOBKIN: I worry.
There are at least two
other David Dobkins
that I'm aware of, because I
get their mail, because we're
conflated in various ways.
I worry about machine learning
algorithm gone a little bit
awry that somehow
puts information
from the three of us together,
assigns it all to me.
This semester, as
it turns out, I'm
teaching a course on IT policy.
And two of my students are here.
ELIZABETH GARLOW: This forum
is giving us an opportunity
to hear certainly a European and
a North American perspective,
but also a global perspective,
that I think will really enrich
our public policy education.
ANNIE KHOA: And
what's fascinating
is that we talk about
a lot of the issues
in the classroom, but to be
here and listen to practitioners
and academics talk about
the issue from both sides,
working on it from
the research side,
as well as how does this
have policy implications
on marginalized
communities, et cetera,
has been a great
learning experience.
CECILIA ROUSE: Our
third panel of the day,
called "The Internet of
Things, or Is Your Bow Tie
Really a Camera?"
MARGARET MARTONOSI: First
of all, the relevance
of the conference itself --
I think it's really struck
a nerve with a lot of people
to examine what democracy means
in a era where information
flows so freely in
many ways and what's
technology's role in that.
And I think it's particularly
important for technologists
to be a part of that discussion.
JULIA BOORSTIN: Nick,
give us some examples
of ordinary use cases
where things might not
talk to each other perfectly.
NICK FEAMSTER: Sure.
I think even though
this panel is called --
it refers to the
internet of things,
I think it's a little
bit of a misnomer.
We should really just think
of it as the internet.
And by that, I
mean, increasingly,
we're seeing more
and more devices
that have a Wi-Fi radio
just baked into them.
So it's cool now to have an
internet-connected thermostat.
Pretty soon everything
you buy is basically
going to be connected
to the internet.
So what does that mean?
Well, when I buy a
house or sell a house
and there are now 100 things
connected to the internet,
from the thermostat to the
door locks to the wall switches
to the light bulbs,
I'm not going
to disassociate with all those.
I'm not going to --
there's no easy way
to delete all my data.
So what's the factory
reset for my house?
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER: We
are grateful that Neelie
can join us here today to
address a critical question --
have we lost control
of the internet?
Please welcome Neelie Kroes.
NEELIE KROES: It is not only
about debating and discussing
in this audience, for this
is an outstanding audience --
international, very
competent and knowledgeable.
But it's also talking
about how can we
implement what will
be, at the end,
be concluded during
this conference.
Leaking has become a
fact of our daily life.
Leaks in the White House,
leaks via WikiLeak --
we witness an unprecedented
amount of orchestrated
leaks via foreign countries.
And the latest news
is interesting --
but you got it
already, which led
to disrupt the elections
of the free world.
LAURA ROBERTS: So
I'm a third-year Ph.D.
student in computer
science at Princeton.
I'm here with other Princeton
students as volunteers.
JASMIN PELED: Students
coming from different majors,
different areas of interest.
We have graduate students
and undergraduate students,
people getting their masters,
people getting their Ph.D.s,
people like me who are
still undergraduate --
it's a whole group of us.
GABRIEL STENGEL: We're
about to do a Facebook Live
event, answering some
questions about Berlin,
about things we've
learned at the forum.
ROSE KELLY: Hi, I'm Rose Kelly
from the Woodrow Wilson School,
and we are live on Facebook Live
from the Princeton-Fung Global
Forum in Berlin.
I'm here with our
student volunteers.
We're going to ask them
a couple questions.
And we've been really
pleased that we've
had so many German media
attend this year's event.
We had 40 reporters sign up.
We've had some great
experiences with some TV crews.
And we've been really
thankful for their coverage.
ELISABETH DONAHUE:
Humboldt University
and Princeton University
have a special relationship.
And it takes on many different
types of connections.
CLAUDIA SCHMIDT-MEMMLER: My name
is Claudia Schmidt-Memmler.
And I work at the International
Strategy Office at Humboldt
University here in Berlin.
And we are an international
strategic partner
of Princeton University.
And I am responsible for
the connection to Princeton
and the connection between
Humboldt and Princeton.
And that's why I'm here.
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER:
Please join me
in welcoming Microsoft
President Brad Smith.
[APPLAUSE]
Brad --
BRAD SMITH: Thanks, Chris.
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER:
Thank you.
BRAD SMITH: I thought it
was worth taking a page out
of the history
books and thinking
a little bit about the
diplomatic conference
that had convened
in Geneva in 1949 --
the diplomatic conference
that had created
the Fourth Geneva
Convention that protects
civilians in times of war.
And I thought it was worthwhile
to start to talk about creating
a digital Geneva Convention --
a convention that would
bring the governments
of the world together,
at least those
that are like-minded, so that
they would pledge and create
new international law.
HANS-CHRISTOPH BOEMERS: I
came to Princeton in 1956
as a graduate student in
the Woodrow Wilson School.
So far, I must say I'm
not disappointed at all.
It's been a very
good conference.
And especially today,
the speech by Brad Smith
was really extraordinary.
CECILIA ROUSE: Now
I'd like to introduce
our fourth panel, entitled
"Communication Silos
and Information Overload."
GABRIELLA COLEMAN: Visual
culture really matters.
Psychological studies
show that if you
have a statement with
an image, more people
are likely to believe it.
And even though a
lot of their images
are kind of totally
ridiculous, because they're
these funny, weird memes
like Hillary like a zombie --
nevertheless, there's
something very
compelling about a
statement -- sometimes
a very catchy statement,
funny statement,
transgressive statement --
and then the image.
And that kind of circulates
all over the place.
YOUNGSUK CHI: I'm so
glad to see Princeton
able to leave the cozy
campus and come out
to the rest of the
world to gather
really thoughtful
minds of experts
to address these issues
under the Princeton banner.
JILLIAN YORK: As a Microsoft
president said earlier today,
all of these companies
produce transparency reports.
And they're quite excellent when
it comes to what governments
are asking of them.
So if a government
asks for a user's data
or asks for a piece of
content to be taken down,
you can go to Facebook
or Google or Microsoft
and find some information
about what that
looks like in those countries.
But when it comes to terms
of service take-downs,
we know nothing.
When we think about
democracy and the internet,
a lot of times we think
about how nation-states
are restricting what we can do.
But in fact, today
corporations like Facebook
have more users than the
entire country of China.
And so we need to think
about the new paradigms
in which these
companies are enacting
control over so many people.
ROGER DINGLEDINE:
I think privacy
is one of the key ways of
becoming free and staying free
on the internet.
I remember being up here
probably six or seven years ago
or something, when I was talking
about the Tor Bridge design
to get around
censorship and basically
provide a way for
Tor users to not get
oppressed by certain
countries around the world.
And at the very end,
there was a person
who came up in the Q&A session.
And his question was simply,
in a very thick Russian accent,
they'll kill you.
And there I am in the CCC video
with my mouth open thinking,
how do I answer a
question like this?
And eventually,
I figured it out.
It was, then I guess
I'd better build it
so that killing me doesn't
actually -- isn't actually
a useful step to take.
So here I am back in Berlin.
CECILIA ROUSE: Our last
panel is "Living With
and Regulating Web 3.0 Plus."
NIVA ELKIN-KOREN:
Unless you take down
the materials that are allegedly
copyright infringement,
you might be liable
for copyright damages.
EDWARD FELTEN: These
days, encryption
is a best practice, really,
to protect your security
and privacy when you're online.
If you're on a public
Wi-Fi network like, say,
the one in this room, and
you go to a website that's
unencrypted, that's actually
a somewhat risky thing to do.
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER:
I thank them.
I thank all of you for what has
been a wonderful conference.
And I invite you all to join us
for a reception, which will be
downstairs on the first floor.
Thank you for being a
part of this. Good night.
[APPLAUSE]
YUSUF DAHL: The
forum's wrapping up.
It was two days of just
amazing conversations
and an opportunity
to really meet
and network with folks
throughout the world.
So it was a outstanding
event, a great weekend.
And I'm thankful
for the opportunity
to hear so many
different perspectives
on this critical issue.
[MUSIC PLAYING]